[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen uh we have a very
special treat for you this evening our
good friend stephen ho has been here
many times
and he always instructs me in the art of
combat and i flourish in those arts
tonight
knock it off tonight
he's back to teach me some iconic moves
from the father of modern martial arts
the great bruce lee stephen ho thank you
for being here that's amazing now
stephen
uh you and i have worked together a lot
over the years i understand bruce lee
was your main inspiration for getting
into what it is you do yeah i think
bruce lee was the most iconic martial
arts in history okay he was a huge
influence for me and the entire martial
arts community all right we actually
just to familiarize anyone who hasn't
seen it recently we have a clip here uh
from a classic bruce lee film game of
death to familiarize ourselves with the
master let's take a look
[Music]
okay i got it yeah
all i had to do was see that and i think
i memorized it all i am ready to go do
you think i can pull this off yeah let's
experience the essence of bruce okay
first i'm going to warm up and really
get into the bruce lee mode right here
now
as
you saw in the as you saw in the clip
yes yes bruce was very fluid fluid and
he believed in in life and in fighting
to be like water to clean water you must
be like water many people have told me
i'm a lot like water well you're not as
uh
coordinated or graceful probably as
bruce was but you you have long i'm
sorry what a dicky thing to say
right here up top when i look like this
you will pay for your words what's the
first thing i have to know let's get
warmed up
yeah okay what do i have to learn start
on a fighting session let's just open up
our hips open up our hips kind of like
that okay i'm pretty good at that if you
know what i mean so
now that he's now that you kind of have
that let's extend her i look like a
banana having a seizure that's what i
what how is this doing okay what do i do
let's extend our this is called a
crescent kick so same thing but you
extend your leg and you go out and
around in a circle it looks like a dance
kick but if you put some some torque on
whoa that was incredible it becomes very
dense did you i felt and i felt myself
go back in time
i met lincoln for a second that wasn't
you want to try it yeah what do i have
to do to go that show me one more time
how do you do it you go go from here up
and around up and around so you you
bring the knee up and then around now
right okay
okay so now the only thing
oh
wow you got you gotta you gotta make
sure you're hitting me four you gotta
keep going what are you hitting me for
you gotta keep your guard up you didn't
say anything about keeping my guard up
we did at the last show we talked about
that okay okay so let's do the same
thing guys so but keep your guard up
there okay my guard's up and up good
look at that
good perfect perfect perfect
okay that's good
how come we have
[Applause]
i am like water okay
so keep that in mind okay and now let's
work on footwork okay footwork okay so
so bruce in the 60s was one of the few
martial artists that actually was
inspired by western boxing okay so in
the 60s most martial artists had really
traditional stances yeah and bruce
believed in doing that but also staying
light like a cat like a cat so he was
very much like a cat like a cat or like
a bull in a very strong stance so you i
would move between being a cat
right
and being
a bull so that's our drill we're gonna
do so why are they here
seriously i thought they were from the
audience for a second
i've noticed in the past when we've done
drills like this you would often hide
behind your desk yeah so these gentlemen
will say that it's also a great bruce
lee technique
[Applause]
uh when he's been doing office work yeah
uh so wait they're here if i try to run
away they're going to do what they're
going to hit you okay yeah
all right so you stay here with me okay
we didn't discuss any of this at
rehearsal all right
and what do you want i'll use my hall
counts
this is not a standard fighting scenario
bruce lee i've seen all the movies he
never encountered a guy with large green
hulk hands okay so when i when i say cat
right do your bruce lee cats they let
him
there you go
more coordination more coordination more
coordination what's wrong with one
another
now boom boom boom get in the bowl
stance
fighting stance guys coming tighter
tighter tighter let's bring it in okay
okay here we go this
here we go and tat tap tap tap tap tap
tap tap
ball ball strike the ball freeze
cat cat dab down
wait a minute
wait a minute hey
what kind of crappy exercise was that
i learned nothing there you should have
learned to be more like water you got to
go with the flow yeah with what's around
you where are they going
they're going to renew their gym
membership
they'll be back i'm like water and then
i lose my
breath easily okay here we go okay
what's the most iconic bruce lee move uh
one inch punch for sure one inch one
each punch
so one inch punch brews did this in 1964
at the long beach uh international
quality tournament and it's a technique
not a fighting technique but a technique
to show that you can generate power
with speed and technique if you're only
one inch away correct as opposed to
having big mass or having to wind up
right so i'm going to do this on you but
i have to warn you that
it can cause internal damage it could
cause your heart to explode let's crack
a sternum so i have this
then why do it at all well i have this
pad for you
this is going to protect me
it'll i'm not going to go full power
okay okay this is like a foam ritz
cracker all right this is just to give
you an idea so very slowly from here one
inch punch and then i torque in like
that okay so not a big you didn't really
do it really do it well let me take this
off okay let me show you this wait no no
no oh ow okay
okay i didn't do it i didn't yeah but
you went low why'd you do that because i
want to avoid your heart you mean you
could stop my heart from beating i don't
know we could try okay
we're okay
let me try it on you for a second okay
okay pretty like that
it seems to have no effect on you you
have to remember you need to oh you need
to torque make sure you torque
make sure you turn okay it's going again
all right
that's incredible that's incredibly
powerful yeah you can get a lot of you
can get a lot of power off that you can
get a lot of power out of one inch i
know that
okay don't do that don't
let's not do that
now
now
that was low
i shouldn't have done that i apologize
you know they encouraged me that's the
problem
it didn't work on me but maybe we'll try
it on the board okay what's on the board
what is this oh okay okay so we're going
to do the same thing i actually when i
was in south korea they taught me this
so i did work on this a little bit with
the board so one inch
just make sure if you hit it incorrectly
you're going to break a finger
so be aware of that
okay okay from here remember our
breathing that we've done we did a few
years ago yeah inhale exhale and then on
the exhale
power through
[Applause]
we're killing the bruce lee brown right
now
all right what's happening here so
before bruce lee
this looks like a
[Applause]
i'm gonna leave it alone okay this one
you can write the joke for this at home
okay
before bruce film fighting was mostly
john wayne punches yes big round right
yeah and now bruce introduced the kicks
yes so this is a roundhouse kick because
you know kicks are obviously a little
bit more difficult since we're not using
our you know our hands we use more often
yes so i'll show you the power of a kick
and then we'll we'll practice with you
okay okay are you ready
how'd you do that
you take this foot back
this foot goes back right what happens
well let's try it okay what do i do
bruce bruce also believed that boards
don't hit back he didn't okay i've been
training with wood so right would you
like to try a kick on a person yes i
would love to do it okay so let's come
over here oh it's not you why isn't it
you
it'll be my cousin okay all right let's
get in here kale
this is kale
yeah
the guy over there that
looking pretty good to you huh sir yeah
okay so this is called a power side kick
it's bruce's favorite kick power
sidekick our side kick so this is how it
starts just a quick refresher we've done
this before okay left leg steps behind
you or you can skip up if you're more
comfortable yeah pick up your right knee
and then it kicks out and then you go
out like that and you want to get them
away you got to lift your knee lift your
knee knee okay it's tearing there's a
carrying in the groin let's come closer
to the whole groin area just turn the
kill okay right here so slide walk
through uh and then bang that's a little
low right you want me to go up higher i
could also go lower
okay all right so up high
and then right there you go and push
through okay all right so be like water
flowing keep energy
okay
you ready okay here we go ready yeah
let's start with your right foot right
here okay
okay there you go focus look there look
there why are you looking down all right
okay yeah i got constructed because i
was thinking about a movie uh okay
transformers it was bad there we go
three two one go
[Music]
i don't know okay
okay so
i completely miss him
i completely miss him let's try that
again okay okay
[Applause]
okay so
better
more twerk more torque so meaning when
you're using your leg right now you're
just using your leg right yeah right you
use your upper body and torque into it
okay right okay right i almost thought
of the same thing
oh lovers okay here we go
okay and three two one go
okay
[Applause]
that was bruce lee also channeling a
chicken uh
i could tell he helped me out a bit
there that's okay a little bit a little
bit okay yeah so now we're gonna
recreate a scene from return of the
dragon where bruce lee kicked a bad guy
into um a box wall oh i remember that
one bruce lee versus the wall of boxes
exactly yeah so now you have four five
people to kick against okay
so we're just gonna go in in succession
we'll go sidekick bounce back sidekick
bounce back and all the way through okay
all the way through so this is imagine
i'm in a i'm in an alleyway
made of cardboard
and five guys with foam
and then a six guy who looks like he's a
hitter for the boston red sox show up
out of nowhere to attack me okay it's
perfect that's my motivation you give me
a q1 let's start right here okay and
action
[Applause]
stephen hall ladies and gentlemen